under Dubai steel starring Shaquille
O'Neal directed by Kenneth Johnson
released in 1997
uh no well that's good because I was
about to say relationship over I still
don't know why it's in our house though
I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
[Music]
ah the late 90s when superhero movies
were still figuring themselves out and
MBA stars got to be in movies welcome
back to another Hilary asti review today
we are going to be talking about steel
this is not a good movie I just watched
it in preparation for this review
because that's the hardest part
of these hilarious tea reviews I
actually have to sit down and I gotta
watch them all so after a very boring
opening credits sequence in which we get
a whole bunch of static unmoving shots
of lava falling down various places and
the incredibly over-the-top theme for
this movie we get the cliched it's only
a test
opening scene you see stuff that looks
like it's dangerous and all of a sudden
people come out and go hey that was
pretty good good job all these weapons
are going well I like this this is gonna
be a lot of fun yes that's right it's
all only a test and Shaq is trying to
explain to everyone this new technology
he's developed they could neutralize a
whole bunch of soldiers without actually
killing them and Judd Nelson's there -
what Judd Nelson's the villain in this
movie okay but guess what the opening
line of this movie is I smell some nuts
roasting now when the guy was writing
this movie and by the way he's also the
director Kenneth Johnson someone told
him that's a good opening line like he's
actually he was writing a script and he
was like that's good that's how we'll
open the thing no Kenneth Johnson is a
director who was primarily known for
television I grew up watching The
Incredible Hulk television show he
directed many episodes including the
pilot now when I was a kid in the 90s
this sci-fi channel became a channel in
America I watched The Incredible Hulk
show I watched the original spider-man
show all 13 episodes of it the
live-action one so automatically you can
tell then a few shots Shaq has this
thing for this girl named Sparky they
like to touch their fingers a lot like
et and Eliot and there's a lot of
foreshadowing with Judd Nelson's
character because he's obviously going
to be a villain that's right he fucks up
the entire mission and now Sparky's in a
wheelchair and we hate him
[Music]
now the filmmakers were obviously trying
to make her basically be the Oracle
character from the comics in fact
there's a few attempts that try to be
like the comics in this movie because
there you have John Henry irons who was
very inspired by Superman to become who
he is and shack himself has the Man of
Steel tattoo right here so it kind of
worked I guess I think those are the
only things in this film that even
remotely resemble anything in the comics
so Shaq is trying to save Sparky and he
basically looks like he's taking a giant
shit I mean look at that face just look
at it he really honestly looks like he's
constipated and he's just trying to let
one out we all know Shaq is tall okay
the dude is 71 but this just looks
hilarious I can't help but laugh when I
see this shot so Sparky's in the
hospital she's not gonna be able to walk
and the doctor is like nope it's not
happening it's like it's really obvious
like nope you're not gonna ever walk
again shot jack decides to return home
to the City of LA and guess what yeah
he's gonna try to shoot a basketball
[Music]
now you think that would be like the
only basketball reference in the film
right it's not there will be more so
quickly we realized that Shaq knows like
every single child in the city like what
he's like 130 I know all these 12 year
olds like what does that even mean is
this some sort of oh I know it's said in
Shaq's contract that he has to know a
lot of kids so that kids can like him as
a basketball star and it'll boost his uh
you know his demo for that age probably
shouldn't we meet grandmom and she gives
even more awkward sugar kisses then
SpongeBob's grandma does don't you
patronize me young man you just give me
some most sugar and she really is trying
to make a souffle she doesn't want
anyone to talk while she bakes the
souffle this is a very important story
element trust me it it actually is a
very important story element to this
movie and it it's brought up quite often
so Shaq apparently just obtains a steel
mill job and we have an entire scene
dedicated to girls thinking he's hot
it's like the entire first act of this
movie the filmmakers were contractually
obligated to just make Shaq look good
now if you're watching this film like I
am it's right around this time that you
may notice that just about every single
song in this movie is some sort of
hip-hop R&B song
[Music]
this is a DC Comics film not checks
personal mixtape but we got to go back
to Judd Nelson right because he's the
big evil bad guy this movie he
dispatches us some pesky side characters
with his magical elevator braking button
there's quite a bit of magical movie
technology in this movie we'll get to
that later
so Jed Nelson's goons robbed a bank with
a laser gun and Shaq just so happens to
be driving with one of his friends who
is a female police officer and a kid in
the back that he's buddies with she gets
a call on the radio that this is going
on and she goes into a firefight with
two passengers in her car this is LA
couldn't you've been like um I have a
child and a friend with me in my vehicle
while I'm on duty I know I don't want to
get fired but I feel like I kind of have
to say that so please send someone else
to the laser gun firefight no of course
not she goes right into the firefight
and Shaq and the kid escape while she's
still in the car which gets blasted over
and then Shaq has to save her the funny
thing is the kid goes
so because of a little bit of fire we're
just supposed to let this girl die I
mean she what happened to this kid who
raised that kid oh there's some fire so
let's not save the police officer cuz
you know there's a little bit of fire
over there I guess we'll just forget
about her there's a little fire now you
think this girl would have something to
do with the plot right you know like
maybe a potential love interest or
something guess what she has nothing to
do with the plot seriously she has
nothing to do with the movie she
literally is a plot device they needed
shaq to somehow be in the streets of LA
at night in the middle of a gunfight so
they had him know a female cop who would
end up going to this gunfight so Shaq
could be in the gunfight and see these
weapons and be like oh sure there's ooh
guns oh man we're shooting another
free-throw it missed because that's what
I do so Shaq gets really pissed at these
guys and he says you're sawing now but
now starts the slowest running chase
ever I mean this is ladies just like doo
doo doo doo doo de doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo
apparently they couldn't find a stunt
double for Shaq because he's like seven
foot one now I know they used this stunt
double for some of the motorcycle scenes
cuz you can just tell but that's because
he's sitting down crouched over he can
hide his height but for these chase
scenes is just shag running it's like
he's running up and down the court just
kind of jogging to his position you know
it's just crazy even the music feels
like it's a slow scene like the music is
very repetitive like oh here we go he's
gonna run now
so Shaq catches the kid that he's
chasing then all of a sudden some goon
just appeared out of nowhere
how I mean they just had to cross like
ten railroad tracks with moving trains
and then this thing just he's just there
so now Shaq is really mad and he really
wants to beat up some of these kids
seriously these gangs with these laser
guns they're all kids they're like 14
kids don't join gangs gangs have laser
guns guns or bad and laser guns are
worse don't join the gangs Shaq is your
friend watch him on TV when he plays
basketball please please and like him if
you're a kid please so he goes to visit
sparks who's in like some physical
therapy thing and I swear to you
throughout this entire scene I thought
she was blind somehow like she just she
sells blindness throughout this scene I
actually thought that she was faking
being blind for like two minutes just to
make a joke to Shaq and it would be like
a really funny but no she's just that's
what she's doing she looks like she'd
tell me if I showed you that scene and
said this is a blind woman would you
believe me yes of course you would look
she looks what is that check out checks
eyebrow twitching in this shot this is a
prime example of should happen my god
that was worse than the fucking garbage
day guy carpet day
[Music]
now we're introduced to Uncle Joe finder
of complicated computer thingies
that's a mainframe 7200 IBM 500
megahertz slam bam thank you ma'am
sudden other so sparks and John Henry
irons and Uncle Joe team up and now
there's super people and they're gonna
fight crime and build steel costumes
that look like shit now like I said you
would think that first basketball pun
would be like the only one right do you
know why Michael Jordan worked in Space
Jam because he played himself he played
a basketball player he did not push the
boundaries he just he was like look I'm
gonna be Michael Jordan let's play some
basketball space jam in this movie Shaq
is like an odd amalgamation of his
actual self and this superhero at the
same time and it just they had to make
him play basketball and not be able to
shoot free throws they just they just
had to that didn't they so of course the
kid is now joining Judd Nelson's gang of
laser gun-toting children because at
some point in the movie he's gonna have
to put a gun to that kid's head to make
Shaq do something he wants them to do so
now we get the montage because every
superhero film has a montage building
and preparing that's just there in like
every one of them some of them are
awesome and some of them are from the
movie steel that came out in 1997 and we
get to watch him make his stupid fucking
costume that looks so shitty it's
supposed to be steel but like almost
every time he moves his mouth you can
see the little steel things on the side
going like this like every time he moves
his made it so the poor John Hawks shows
up and gives the best performance in the
whole damn movie it's interesting to see
how some of these oscar-nominated actors
start histah never get the first big
superhero rescue scene and of course
it's a bunch of slow ass action again
with Shaq just jogging around did you
didn't did you dude
during this scene we get the ball shot
finger wave that's what I call it
[Music]
can you believe that that was actually
filmed like me I mean it's like they
filmed that and then Uncle Joe says
possibly the best line in the movie even
though it's it's like the worst line in
the movie but it's the by far the
funniest line in the movie shit and roll
in breadcrumbs okay and I'm done I'm
done I'm done
so after Shaq dispatches of some thugs
one of his leg plates falls off and I
think they wanted us to think that that
was planned and scripted but it honestly
looks like a blooper like it looks like
a gag like Shaq's best performance in
this movie is when he goes like oh it
fell like he did it really looks like it
was like it actually just fell and he
falls off a building and it's so
incredibly obvious you can see the line
attached back here is just there's the
line it's right there and of course he
falls in a dumpster because whenever
someone falls off a building you don't
want to die there's gonna be a dumpster
down there a big dumpster big enough for
a seven-foot one basketball player to
fall into so the cops start to follow
him in a big chase ensues this is my
favorite part little chase okay the cop
makes the home alone face I swear to you
he makes the home alone face it's
amazing check it out
I left so friggin hard oh my gosh it was
amazing and this is the first time in
the movie where this happens it seems
like a person cursed but they like
edited it because they were afraid the
MPAA would give them an R or something I
don't know it's just amazing son of a
but who says son of a but no one says
son of a but it couldn't do they could
just cut the line out no it says son of
a but wow you're a son of a but who in
the hell says that no one no one on this
earth says that just that one cop son of
a but I'm gonna start saying that now so
check makes it back safely and of course
they do the finger thing again and you
know at this point it's already getting
kind of tired it happens a lot more
trust me and guess what else is in this
scene leisure records intact what a
basketball joke so at this point Judd
Nelson begins his big evil plan to
showcase all of his awesome evil
weaponry to people at this time please
notice that throughout this entire film
whenever there is a nighttime action
sequence of some kind the streets of LA
are always deserted completely deserted
because you can just tell they've got it
all blocked off for the scene there's
never cars
there's never traffic nothing look I
just spent a weekend in LA and I can
tell you that all night all I heard was
traffic where the hell's the traffic so
Shaq shows up and starts blasting people
in another slow a shootout let me set up
what happens next okay these guys are
robbing the Federal Reserve with laser
guns there is a seven-foot one maniac in
a steel costume shooting at those thugs
with another laser gun they send one
police car one one I was just in LA
literally this weekend okay and some
people were fighting outside of a movie
theater we
all like eight police cars go there I'm
not even King like eight to ten police
cars for two people fist-fighting
yeah and guess what the two cops that
are in the cars same cops from before so
a helicopter shows up and a thug looks
up blasts the helicopter the helicopter
is now falling oh my gosh it's gonna
fall on the home alone macaulay culkin
cop
so steel is running you know kind of
slowly and he tackles the cop and saves
him from the helicopter but does he
really save him no he doesn't because
look
there was like 30 feet in between him
and alle copter because this is so
obvious and poorly filmed that he wasn't
actually in danger but they're trying to
make us think he was but for stories
sake we have to think that he was
because it's important for later now we
get an inspirational scene with grandma
where she feels they have to whisper to
maintain a well-cooked souffle in her
oven what all of a sudden some guy just
burst through her kitchen window Shaq
attacks him starts throwing people
around and we find out it's a SWAT team
it's a SWAT team with a search warrant
because they suspect of him being
involved with the weapons the SWAT team
came through the kitchen window by
breaking it open right in front of this
80 year old grandma so the home alone
macaulay culkin cop doesn't want to ID
Shaq in the lineup because he tackled
him to the pavement when there was
actually no danger at all from the
helicopter and you know like I said
we're supposed to believe that he saved
him but you know they were like 30 feet
away from the helicopter they were fine
if a seven-foot one guy wearing nothing
but steel tackled me to the asphalt I'd
be fucking pissed but I also want to
point out that in this scene he takes
his earpiece out from his mouth and puts
it in his ear and he has contact with
Sparky now know I'm gonna estimate that
at least three hours have passed during
that time from when he was taken by the
SWAT team to the line up to being locked
up in jail and the earpiece that he's
had in his mouth that entire time
collecting saliva
it still works of course because magical
movie technology so where they're
supposed to find where these advanced
military weapons are going to be sold
where is Judge Nelson gonna do his big
deal well in 1997 the internet was still
relatively new to some people and not
everyone had it and not everyone was as
experienced with it as we are now so the
filmmakers had the plot point deed that
Judge Nelson made a web page where he's
selling his illegal weaponry that every
law-enforcement agency on the fuck
earth is looking for the Internet damn
right we can pick up all kinds of good
crap not just porn oh he just made a
website seriously like I mean all you'd
have to do is just fucking there's the
webpage with the illegal weapons you
just type it in and there it is so Shaq
is freed from jail by magical movie
technology with Sparky's voice being
changed to the voice of a district
attorney and it's it's all just perfect
within minutes he is in his full steel
suit going to some address that Sparky
got with her magical movie technology
again and Judd Nelson's there trying to
sell his weaponry to a whole bunch of
different buyers so when Shaq is
observing this area from afar he notices
there's a guy with some dogs some very
vicious looking dogs he pops out his gun
at this point he reveals that his gun
actually has a very high frequency dog
whistle now two things one you're in a
full body steel costume who gives a shit
about a couple dogs you're fine the dogs
will not affect your full body steel
costume number two what the fuck is a
dog whistle doing on advanced military
weaponry what is the practical
application of a dog whistle on a laser
gun there should have been a scene where
he was like well I guess she was right
to include that in the gun or something
that led us in on the joke of a dog
whistle being on a gun he's got a dog
whistle it literally goes well at the
top of his gun and it emits a high
frequency nevermind so the big finale
starts with the perfect oh shit they've
got the girl shot so at this point Judd
Nelson starts killing every single one
of his business associates right in
front of his potential buyers
what a fantastic business strategy I'm
sure all of them want to sign contracts
with this guy now so a guard is
threatening Uncle Joe but his dog
lilly saves him wait a second I thought
oh that's Lilly she wasn't like so Shaq
actually successfully tempts Judd Nelson
to push the red button and of course he
does
engaging his electromagnet his gun
shoots back to Shaq's chest and Sparky
starts to shoot laser beams out of her
wheelchair she's shooting pulsating
sonic beams out of her wheelchair
couldn't they have at least shown her
put the brakes on or something you think
she'd just like shoot back where I mean
when you're a person and you shoot a
regular gun it goes like that okay
pulsating sonic beams that can blast
through Federal Reserve walls would
she's in a wheelchair they could have at
least showing her blast backwards or
something her head shacked like put his
hands on it and like aim her that would
have been cool a guy Isis a grenade in
the room with Shaq and the kid and the
kids like there's a hole up there you
got to throw the grenade through the
hole and Shaq's like I swear to you the
grenade doesn't go off for like 20
seconds it's the worst grenade in the
world now I'm telling you guys I'm gonna
mimic my exact reaction when I saw this
scene okay this was my reaction
I never made these
and follow-through come on
[Music]
[Applause]
so Shaq reflects a giant blast back to
Judd Nelson steals a car saves the day
and nearly kills Sparky and Uncle Joe in
the process so Judd Nelson is dead and
everyone has a party at Grandma's house
and she brings out her perfect souffle
that fucking thing has more character
development than anyone in this movie
and then I'm just going to show you this
scene because I really can't you just
have to see it
[Music]
I love a girl yep that's steel it was
shown in theaters around the world
thousands of screens it's a movie that
actually exists guys thank you so much
for watching my hilarious T review of
steel hall man it's not a good one but I
appreciate you guys watching and I will
do more hilarious ''tis because I really
enjoyed doing them and thanks for all of
your great requests as well guys thank
you so much for watching and as always
if you liked this you can click right
here
[Music]